um this is uh this is kind of funny
fox news and other right-wing media have
gone
silent
on ivermectin one of the popular
promoted quote treatments for kovid that
many on the right-wing media have
promoted instead of vaccination
have promoted as a reason why we don't
really need to take precautions very
early before there was any evidence they
said ivermectin works
and now that we have multiple studies
that shows ivermectin doesn't work for
covid
for covid some people miss that they go
david it works fine for horse deworming
or for parasitic infections
does it work for kovid no
fox news hasn't issued an apology
as far as i know uh rogan and others
haven't issued apologies
they just aren't talking about
ivermectin anymore so let's go back a
little bit
early in the pandemic
i was right there in the forefront i
think it was it was march of 2020 if not
april of 2020 and i came to you and i
said hey here's a bunch of stuff that is
being looked at and it should be looked
at there's this thing called
hydroxychloroquine should be looked at
it's being tested
um there is uh azithromycin does it have
a possible antiviral effect it's going
to be studied we should study it a
combination of i believe it was hiv
drugs that were being looked at what
about taking the zpac with zinc or with
vitamin d and i said to you there's
eight to twelve different things we
don't know if they work for covid they
should be studied they are being studied
and
different right-wing media fixated on
one or two of them and said this just
works we have a treatment this works
open everything early they fixated on
hydroxychloroquine eventually it became
a focus on ivermectin today we know
ivermectin doesn't work for covid
right-wing media touted it for months
and months and months they were
convinced that it works convinced that
there was a cover-up because it's cheap
and they don't want you to they don't
want you to know they used ivermectin
promotion to cast out on the vaccine
while pushing something unproven you
even even had people saying the vaccine
is deadly alex berenson said it tucker
carlson said on his show it seems that
thousands tens of thousands of people
may have died from the vaccine i mean
really crazy dangerous stuff
while promoting ivermectin and claiming
they
don't want you to know about it and they
don't want you to have it we now know it
doesn't work okay and yet fox hosts
pushed anecdote anecdote after anecdote
after anecdote and in fact mediaite has
a great sample of them in january of
last year
laura ingram said a friend of hers took
ivermectin after getting coven and she
got better now what's the problem with
that it's the same problem that exists
with a lot of homeopathic treatments
which is a lot of things get better
without doing anything for example
headaches
wow you know i uh i had a terrible
headache
and then i ate a papaya with peanut
butter and the next day i felt better
well yeah most people's headaches get
better
and it's the same thing with covet most
people get better from covid i could say
you know i uh
i had covid
and i decided to burn a bunch of tennis
balls sprinkle cinnamon on it and
breathe the fumes and within five days i
was better of covered this is not how we
study stuff particularly when you expect
a regression to demean you you expect
that most people are going to get better
okay in september brian kilmeade
suggested ivermectin could treat covid
saying sometimes drugs work for
different things yeah off-label uses are
a thing there was just no evidence
ivermectin worked for covet in december
ben carson said ivermectin is effective
against covet there was no such evidence
two weeks later tucker carlson
interviewed a psychiatrist who said
ivermectin could be a lifesaver now my
dad's a psychiatrist
he would not go around telling you what
works to treat covet because that's not
his area of expertise
there were 300 or so such instances but
now we have the data from actual studies
we have a study called efficacy of
ivermectin treatment on disease
progression among adults with mild to
moderate covid19 and comorbidities and
cova doesn't work
i'm sorry ivermectin doesn't work for
covet i wish kova didn't work ivermectin
doesn't work for covid and now fox news
and other right-wing media are silent
it's just not a topic anymore like
they've talked about it 300 times and i
don't have any clips to show you because
there there are no clips they're not
talking about it anymore it's like they
always do it they just go silent this
actually happened with
hydroxychloroquine just think back we
did a clip
in april of 2020 called trump and fox go
silent on hydroxychloroquine because
studies came out after a month of
talking about hydroxy saying it doesn't
work for covet so then they just never
talked about it again another example
february fox goes silent moment after
massive jobs report they promoted and
predicted a bad jobs report for days up
until the jobs report came out the jobs
report was good joe biden's president we
don't talk about it anymore the media
literacy takeaway here
so there's there's like a covered
takeaway which is the ivermectin doesn't
work we now know that great
there's a media literacy takeaway as
well which is the power
of what you don't talk about this is the
power of story selection and power of
the exclusion of stories i'm not immune
to this like i'll give you an example
people email me they say david why
aren't you talking about hunter hunter
biden's laptop that's right i'm not i
don't think it's a legitimate story to
cover and when i talk about it i talk
about it to tell you
look at how crazy the right is going
about this but i'm not covering hunter
biden's laptop story as a story i did it
once i explained to you all about the
blind computer tech who thinks it might
be hunter biden's lab you know all this
sort of i covered it once i told you
what's being said but i do this too i
ignore some stories because i don't
think that they are stories everybody
does this you just have to understand
whether it's being done in good faith or
in bad faith and every time fox news
gets debunked about whatever a jobs
report hydroxychloroquine ivermectin
you never hear about it again
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at deepakman and next tuesday
april 19th we'll be doing the next david
pakman show viewer town hall it will be
at 6 eastern
and it will be streaming on the pacman
live youtube channel i want to hear from
as many of you as possible that'll be
tuesday april 19th 6 pm on the pacman
live youtube channel quick break right
back
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below